now Avalanche has also released four  glorious trailers all in 4K resolution  showcasing the four Hogwarts common  rooms we'd seen each room briefly before  but these trailers give us our best look  so far at all of the incredible detail  Avalanches including here Ravenclaw  features an orderly bright common room  with plenty of spots for studying  Gryffindor is a welcoming and  comfortable space that shows off school  spirit house pride and a remembrance of  former gryffindors with numerous  portraits Hufflepuff has nailed that  warm earthy feel with plenty of areas  that encourage social interaction and  numerous plants that help bring life to  the space and while Slytherin may be in  the dungeons the vast Windows looking  out into the Black Lake let plenty of  light filter through you'll find bizarre  relics strange items and what has to be  the most jaw-dropping entrance of all  four with the Slytherin common room